hello my name is noel yi and i live at
the vulcan in east oakland california
and this year i'm coming out to
fahrenheit and i'm really excited
i'll be teaching three classes one class
which will be a choreography class
called the process which will be all
about the process of generating
choreography with your friends
another class i'll be teaching will be a
one-handed quarry class which will teach
people the fundamentals of meteor
supermans and more
and the final class i'll be teaching
will be a contact staff tracing class
which will be contact staff tricks with
a little tracing edge which is popular
in poi reasons
so if you live on the east coast i
really look forward to seeing you at
fahrenheit this year